i really am curious to be a fly in the
wall i'm sure it'll happen at some point
watching you and elon talk to each other
because he's even more of a robot than
you
he was on the babylon b podcast and i
was honored to be able to be in the room
while this was happening
and
with the guys at the b do um at the end
of every podcast they have like like 10
questions i don't think this is where
this is one of those no no this and they
go to elon
um would you would you rather be batman
or iron man you know because they're
both like multi-millionaire
industrialists
and elon being elon is like well let's
think this through there's different
kinds of bats you've got you know fruit
bats and you've got insect bats why it's
called batman batman she'll fly right
that's can fly and then iron man and i'm
just sitting there holding dude just
answer the question
it was so literal i was like damn
i guess by this point uh i've released a
podcast with him that's uh
several hours and it's exactly as as as
you would imagine it's exactly as you
would imagine there was this super
technical the movie her
yes of course so there's that one scene
it's when um what is it joaquin who's
the lead character yeah a walking
phoenix yeah so he's the lead and he
falls in love with siri basically who's
played by scarlett johansson
and at there's another artificial ai
that she's talking to
and she's like oh can i uh permission to
go into nonverbal communication with
this professor and
and the guy's like sure and they just
start talking to each other in their
robot and i'm just imagining the two of
you having this mind meld
well that so there's a both the humor of
that
but also the practical nature of the
kind of conversations to have it's it's
so great because it's uh
it's problem solving mode okay yeah yeah
okay it's so that is fun that is
exciting because like you stop
completing sentences i actually feel at
home because you don't need to say the
full sentences anymore you could just
like
say random words and you start to
understand what you're talking about and
then you can have multiple conversations
at the same time and go on these
tangents
one of the biggest problems i have with
podcasting for me talking i have to
finish my sentences i have to actually
finish making a point yeah which is a
big problem because there's like a
listener that needs to hear the point
being finished as opposed to completing
your
sentences uh
in inside your own mind and like the the
the thing i find is useful to yolanda's
exact same thing is
when the line of thinking is no longer
useful you just ran you just switch to
the next thing you just leave that whole
thing behind you don't need a nice
transition you don't need any of that
and also just um
it's the first principles thing it's
like zooming in
on the
on the elephant in the room i love that
it's so energizing just that that's what
i love about engineers it's not the it's
not it's not the maybe most eloquent
communication style but i um
i love it
you